اسقاط البالون الصيني لم يكن قباله سواحل
كارولينا الشماليه وانما انتهى به الامر
على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي لا مكان
للحديث الجاد عن المنطاد الصيني جمهور
يوتيوب وتويتر وفيسبوك لا يرحم
[موسيقى]
والماده الفلميه المجسده لاساطير السلاح
الجو الامريكي اصبحت ماده ساخره
حتى المهمات الصعبه في افلام هوليود لا
تخلو من البالون الصيني
[موسيقى]
ومن عالم هوليود الى عالم السياسه متخذ
قرار الاسقاط اطاح بهم البالون الصيني على
مدرج الطائره
[موسيقى]
ولحظه اسقاط من السماء اثارت اندهاش هيلر
كلينتون وزوجها
[موسيقى]
ولكن ما سيكون رد ترامب على الصين لو كان
في موقع الرئيس
[موسيقى]
البرامج الساخره هي الاخرى لم تترك صراع
امريكا والصين واجرت حوارا بين الطائرات
الحربيه والبندوره
النينجا
في كل تغريده سخريه وكتابه التعليقات على
الفيسبوك تتوالى على الفيديوهات الساخره
في عالم موازن يخفف من وطاه الحماس الزائد
للصرع السياسي
[موسيقى]